Franklin resume Jews in France brands
are the Empire I'm particularly would
like to thank the director the mid-south
all set Jenny here because she gave me
the opportunity to bring this conference
to basil and I would also like to thank
Robert passing for white
and I would also love to thank all of
the participants all of the speakers
because you were so incredibly
cooperative and hardworking and
enthusiastic and it made my job so
pleasurable and I am so grateful so
thank you so much thank you thank the
full term is joining
but how did a great job putting everyone
or anything
notice that we have a bunch of leading
figures in every part and that certainly
true this morning Renee Polanski people
moment is very power when she writes and
speaks everybody listens jeez the aqha
pouria athlon professor of all across
studies at ben-gurion university Shiva
she also teaches a lot in class and
vectors often among these days she's
credibly productive or seeing this fifty
three chapters and articles I will knock
you right now
one of their books I'd like to show how
she tackles of a side
create an indispensable work out of it
two brass 1997 English one
the french word for these works is
actual for not exactly
never mentioned this for no reason book
published in 2008 oh my god if you see
on that basis all see the program please
Angie tak over really sensitive and
delicate subject of how free fries and
the resistance responded with decent a
program with the answer is with
medicines and she doesn't deserve that
she's counties you go to every utterance
every public
and what they said was impeccable but
you can say it very often necessarily
the way to the park
we can
well any officers
forward our subject this morning is
resistance and the rescue of Jews and
friends from history
a conference on Treasure Island
boardwalk you at first sight the trend
lighting
such a project to perfection it seems up
stories of the second world war in
France
Oh
have tend to neglect the overseas
possessions I to create in which respect
our historical analysis and very young
beyond the borders of continental so
this contract is the watershed or
another
please correct me if I'm wrong but
except for a conference on the
resistance sighs organized by Jackson
Markham against who creates 4005 which
relied on a compacted approach this is
the first conference at the measure of
university to deal with the rescue of
the Jews in France one thing so the
centrality the memory of the show up is
acquiring the west of the world that
seems on someone astonishing we must
search all the root causes of this
occasion in the history of the period
itself a history that quarter
historiography until the urgent demands
of memory final shot of the day let me
quote a jack Sigma in comparison to the
impressive videography about the stage
of the stages of the Constitution
rotation and extermination of the Jews
wrote same manganese introduction to the
collect proceeding of the conference
went to the dog studies devoted to
rescue efforts on quite rare but more in
a volume published in 2010 owns in one
feature of this history of
historiography karuna he writes
discussions of natural resistance do not
see often marginalized and help you to
juice and that quite text of the fate of
Jews and the incidence of rescue have
few reflections of the wider context of
resistance as a matter of logic the
story of the rescue of the Jews across
ought to be based on the history of the
resistance in practice it's clear that
since is the only label that can be
applied to help in truth were threatened
with arrest and deportation to East this
common sense of salvation was not safe
in vision I
EOG the rescue of the Jews was
marginalized twice over let's go back to
the early summer of nineteen twenty on
jun 22 after shocking defector defeats
by the german army's friends accepted
the terms of an armistice that dismantle
the country and pave the way for the end
of the Third Republic the injured
province and SAS and Mozelle were torn
away the Germans occupied the capital as
well as we know the part of the country
a new order the French take place in
Republic that was not talking
responsibility for the disaster the
journal has applied de cría to the
comparison throughout your time zone and
myself behind his government in B she
retains sovereignty our lesson out of
French territory the so-called free zone
while he smashes the doctors part of the
National River
apply to all the country this ain't
France bagel recipe and restore its
status in the new Europe it was building
being built in the shadow of the brush
with which the new regime collaborated
activity whatever whatever happens the
flame of French Resistance must not and
shall not die declares an olive oil over
the sea unjoin the 1840 1940 in reaction
to becomes first speech accepting the
defeat certainly the French people to
keep on fighting the gold specified
subjective delivering the danger they
learn the fatherland and remain with the
camp of the ultimate pictured in this
war which was all would be pursued a
world war going beyond the divers
motivations and goals of those who made
away to London
a resistance group on French star the
frame s to be baby goes for speeches
impose a particular reading of events
the resistance was born of a political
decision whose translation on the ground
was gold political and military we might
need to take only one example of the
invention of resistance by those who
later came to hang the bag uncle this
involved meetings to discuss the latest
broke a broadcast London and initial
track postures of the world Paris and
any newspaper resistance which first
appeared to December 1940 from the
artist unset resisting meant making
another world voice herb and applied
every means to denounce collaboration
the Germans speech was at the same
the extraordinary growth of the
diversified underground pressing those
roads is evidence of this as the months
passed the proliferation of networks and
movements the leads to London and the
emergence of the coordinated political
thought it would be ready when the time
came take part in generational Frost and
then pursue political power reinforce
these two dimensions the political and
memory effect at realty resistance to
return to the rigid alone go its members
who discovered another
me healthy prisoners of war escape and
smelling them to southern zone outside
the Germans reach according to German
tijana and particular the escape section
remain the reactivities round 19 40 and
41 hero resistance involved action
rather than works originating in the
individual initiatives but supported by
legal institutions to and I put it to
you again cars & parish houses and
potato places of refuge and even some
visual agency that were both mistaken
rockers these were the same mechanism
that would later play a role in the
rescue of the Jews those help to read to
escape French soldiers and British
Airmen where competence and clearly part
of the war it was natural for the
network's inform to concentrate on bed
rest you for rescues sake with the focus
on civilians and not quite there this is
not generalization of the risk of
civilians within the political
opportunity that gradually emerged was
accompanied by aha generalization of the
fact of necessity to choose although
they were not the only victim of the
occupation just became quickly a
priority target nevertheless the
resistance price navigate to drew the
attention is lavished on the people of
assassin gazelle and next to Germany or
expect on that post or to the course
suffering another German jackals the
children occupied zone for himself
victimized by a jewel anti-semitic
legislation German and fresh as soon as
the 10 or 14 the Germans although the
senton supporters and have the French
police tender
papers three weeks later the Vichy
government issued the Jewish Jewish
tangent and transform the Jews into
second class citizens of the night at
the same time the federal government
abrogated the premio decree of 1870
algerian just lost their French
nationality it authorized prefex to
ensure foreign Jews in a special camp
especially to order this is it made it
possible to send 40,000 foreign Jews to
ken's in the southern load and survey
the legal basis of the roundups which
shade in the Paris region to be internal
or so eight thousand Jews d41 alone the
Vichy government also seized Jewish
property use cuadros ordered by the
German occupation authorities in pursuit
on the pharmacy of a realization of the
economy in June 41 then if allowed the
first commissioner for Jewish questions
completed the anti-semitic legislation
you Jewish static we are not talking
about a new assorted collection of
occasional texts their number several
dozen rose decrease and audiences is
evidence of the first resolution the
subtotal of these laws express the
policy of health public officials
communicate as well as in commentaries
in the national and local press this
sharp and total violation of one of the
fundamental principle the French
Republic was not involved in an element
of the new policy that from the country
assorted Diaries provides evidence of
impact is a anti selling clothes head on
what people were talking about tomorrow
in the analysis he published in London
enough mostly committed them as dps
agenda cookie published in London in
1942 nevertheless the persecution of the
Jews was mentioned only sporadically in
the interview in the world press and
even then in turn that were often quite
ambiguous raw red wine was arrested in
persecution in clear terms in the short
list of exceptions the most remarkable
for will be the Calumet in winnetka tell
me heard about it yesterday which means
production to a special issue and titled
anti-semitism level the harsh document
of the silence that second other
constitutional reviews but then I asked
idea was a minority voice no other end
across publication followed follow we'd
see one reason for this discretion not
to mention silence and difference while
the veneration that much of the
population fell for my shall be done
about that river yesterday as well it
can be associated with the ambiguity
that mark the urn states of working
underground movements which imagining
themselves as completing what the motion
was trying to do though he was compelled
to fail obedience to the occupier it
could also be explained by the
aggressive a propaganda and playing the
juice of the defeat and choose the
resistance leaders of being there
because based on conviction widespread
public opinion and if you could among
some members of the resistance itself
the juice pose a problem that concept to
so has it was inappropriate to be
knowledge to strongly measures that
address this problem was it as real
evenly they were excessive or being
applied at that time ostracism ins that
were simple plan Daenerys from the
spring of 42 the application of the
final solution which was a frost became
the owner of the day the appearance of
the yellow story the streets of Paris
control the occupied zone at the
beginning of 242 clearly indicated this
change arrest followed by deportation to
a terrifying unknown destination begin
the most pressing threat which way on
the entire Jewish population first of
your coop I thought and then all
anti liberation on jhalak 16 and 17 or
42 and 43 more than 13,000 Jews
including more than 4,000 children were
arrested in parents by the French police
as part of the best operation it came to
be known as a ladies ready round up a
final journey in seed freight cars carry
these unfortunate families be Adam see
children included two outfits no yoga's
the truth of the southern zone face the
same threat I'm August 3142 MMO by
National Police Headquarters reported
that more 11,000 hundred and eighty-four
Jews have been happy and it's in the
start of the month and deported between
the end of March and the elif's at ever
42 more than 38,000
imported from France he thought he was
conscious all leading to our she's
heading to us it was during these long
that the underground press are you woke
up mostly these notifications amplify an
outcry of power the safety escort from
every excess paint German temerity was
showing you soon face a french-style the
Jews by the first been seen the preview
to measure that sooner or later would
strike the entire population from
children where we reprogram mothers are
and the French were indignant appalled
in full sympathy with the victim and
especially the innocent children the
indignation was sincere no doubt but it
was expressed exclusively in monetary
terms and then no impact whatsoever on
the gold or practice of the resistance
movements the master s conducted by the
French police continue to wait in those
down and check every of 44 there were
also the constant arrest of individuals
and activity you wish of the note
November
to the German police aided by auxiliary
forces drawn from collaborations groups
we're increasingly involved these
arrests continued and shall be very
liberation of the entire country where
the purple of potential victims kept
kept expanding although almost seventy
six thousand Jews were deported from
France a fool only three percent
survived but after the indignation of
the summer of 42 the resistance price
with your meat silence about the plight
of the Jews while works in vain for the
slightest reference to us work and
waited the Jews deported from France
except 41 f entire game even though
recalls were filtering in circulated by
the Jewish communal space or broadcast
of the BBC which more and more people
were listening despite the prohibition
of doing so the list started other
priorities nobody wanted to
vassals who have been affected by TC and
who as all opinion surveys confirmed
combined a true compassion for the fate
of two children victims of Nazi
barbarism with a fear that an allied
victory would bring back the Jewish
problem the imagine the immediate goals
were to keep young Frenchman and women
from being transported to Germany s post
laborers in the st st OMG hi Deborah and
to make preparation for the liberation
of register so the persecution was not
covered by the resistance price the best
round logs of Jews and their invitation
hardly ever gained attention except on
for short wrong how did the rescue of
the same jewels on the spot or medicine
or resistance activities the welfare
organizations Jewish and non-jewish a we
heard this madness today nevertheless I
did the first to go into action even I
have no assistance devoting themselves
to various groups rattled by Nintendo a
constitution
the American emergency rescue committee
again we heard without directed by
valance I did everything is good to
facilitate the integration of the most
exposed intellectual he opened the no is
he must say as soon as August 1914 and
helped hundreds who escaped from social
workers from various institutions Jewish
and non-jewish what in internment camps
to initiate the deployment cycle there
were also activists notably those of the
Ozzie was set to work at earliest summer
of 40 and by men 49-42 and managed to
free almost all of the children from the
in German came to the southern goal in
Paris the committee are no talking on
jun 15 jun 15 1940 consisted of
representatives of jewish welfare
organizations and a political groups
such as boob on social personal stylist
we are decided to coordinate there are
entities from the beginning they
operated on a dual-track even though the
world was not claim this land
the comedy did not register with the
authorities soon however the vast array
of juice the opening of the internment
camps and then with rotations transform
the group's mission it tells you sneak
over the mountain demarcation line in
the South observe and that's involved in
the production of false papers under the
cover of the Red Cross and packages to
the camp is formed our children
comparing two areas families and it is
tributed cleanse in aid to those not
approach it could not approach to the
organization's most of what these
organizations dealing first was
perfectly legal so the idea of
cooperating to ward off and counter the
threat or certainly they're the only
ones of young organizations that focus
on the plan is to rescue children
whenever hiding them which christian
families or by side smuggling them
across the border to Switzerland or
Spain in the southern zone there were
water to the CCM outros of the release
codes which coordinated inside the
ground activity with those of the
Zionist youth movement this book groups
paid the price for this Mayan coal and
see when most famous beauties but there
were others as well the evolution of the
Osage from legal welfare work responding
progressively to the Jews growing misery
to resistance work focused focused on
rescued is embodying of the great
transformation experienced by many
Jewish and non-jewish welfare and
educational organizations the transition
can be precisely located in the impact
of the mass rondelles of the summer of
42 which also skirt individual
initiatives such as those of us are
under met a buddy who set up the master
networking miss in all these cases what
were called social activity led to a
transformation in the attitude towards
politics of some charitable groups and
accommodated themselves to the existing
political structures as long and they
could continue to carry out their
mission always involved we're aware of
the defines represented by Elliott of
solidarity with the persecuted oh it
looks a master affiliated with the union
at unitarian service committee we
arrived in france
30 41 refer to those expression of
solidarity is the first signs of passive
resistance for ceremonies share the life
and work of his activist when we wrote
in lines he sent down early you return
to the US in january of 1942 am 14 in
the spine is apathy everywhere evident
during my first week in prose was
increasing apparently the only real
effort to float the Nazis was being made
by foreign organizations which were able
to operate in very little fields
inflation restricted feeling and
alliteration of various kind Bruce was
thinking in particular of the emergency
risk committee but also the Quakers of
the Alliance neg the next Oh Donald oh
we refer you referring to the rescue
life I mean I PTPTN of 93 children
during the summer of 42 / founder & to
the assistance extend to the truth by
the residence of shampoo
report proposed in September 32 there
and I'm coaching blowing air to and to
choose involves resistance to the
authorities Rishi so the political
significance of rescuing cheeseburgers
clearly perceived as it was by the
Jewish activist but this very developed
in parallel weeds and in the margin of
history the Casa del H the political and
military history of the resistance in
mail 42 where could read the following
lines in the cognitive architecture
elenco here we would like to set aside a
special place for this miracle and most
relevant form of assistance to the
Resident Assistants providing shelter
providing shelter to all the homeless
all the hunted all of those for pride
person whose number the occupation has
multiplied reading from the Patriots
pursued by the Gestapo to the Jews who
this vesicle is turned into a round room
the right of asylum has become a duty of
asylum in these sentences community
it's health once again set itself apart
from every other and the ground
vegetation this nut isn't escaped the
attention of the boy the organization of
ingrown Jewish families Illinois
starting in the summer of 42 is a grown
publication and when constant dirt
trench people in which the mantra stage
waiting the Jews deported release was
described in a ganar agonizing detail
they implore French family to help
rescue jewels and especially children
now this publication wasted no time
reprinting these lines from the one area
where these haste because they could
facilitate the transition from the
expression of humanitarian feel you to a
political practice which have been
inconceivable before the enactment of
sto in February of 1943 Jack use one of
these in the ground which campus
complication had tried the trigger
misused at that time and I'm quoting
Jack use can we stand aside and we
different
the population of our country to all the
young people who are threatened with
deportation Jewish children are
particularly engagement which workers
and in the world friends workers to
ensure say me one of these children is
not only a human hat but also patriotic
yet the political reason of the
restaurant which children's Club
described and a patriotic act or
difficult to convey as right in July 42
eternity and while attempting to others
and Ron publication runs by the run by
the Jewish colonies referred this time
directly explicitly and immediately to
the stand taken by tamannaah bhatia but
this attempt to integrate the rescue of
Jews into the resistance movement in the
oil was in vain for the other brown
bread groups of the French Resistance
that were working towards the liberation
of the country as well as for three
the fight enter that invitation
deportation of French workers was a
political Kombat any support for acts of
solidarity for the persecuted Jews was a
humanitarian matter a medieval
deliberation the French administration
in as NGOs approached about sixteen
children rescued from frost by the World
Jewish Congress express its gratitude to
this organization for it humanitarian
action the rest of the Jews was
organized at one tonight when the
resistance operated under their own
another the resistance habitus as 80s
Old Covenant values while the rescue
cabbages and others the Jewish
resistance organization grouped in a
committee of general defense were well
aware of these in their application to
join the prof Amos
stuff the organizations focused on the
unique nature of their activities and
importing the letter they sent your is
resistance actions and our we're not
born at the same time and were not
initially of the same nature the low
contenders to be robbed without any
remedy and for most effective
institution without ready so our first
form of resistance was mutual assistance
that was
resistance state the later this had been
followed by the second form of
resistance then escape and defense and
the text continue these products closer
closer to this attempt was to continue
to blogger full and complete publicly
recognized in cooperation of the
wrestler juice into the resistance
movement the first we can trace back to
the sources of the social imaginary
machinist a CL ad to do with the fear of
stirring your demon of the Jewish
problem oh I refer you to the specifics
it take away in the Jews the second was
inseparable from the meaning attached
the resistance ever since its inception
which focused on political opposition to
be she and on the liberation of heart
and did not include resolute forest you
say energy a on January the six 1943
general the good side an ordinance which
was closed legitimized and encoding the
audience all as committed out after June
the 10th 1940
with a goal of serving the cause of the
liberation of France even if they were
criminal under the legislation in force
in that period a general elastic of
those wages false papers to protect
himself during the war was declared in
January 45 it was based on this
ordinance how could those Jews who
facing Constitution during the
occupation and forge or use false
identity cards to escape the death that
provision please demonstrate that they
had done so in order to cheap different
from 12 different house rescue has no
train no intrinsic value the persecution
of the Jews was not perceived in its
collective meaning the double
marginalization survived liberation well
what my tonight advanced transition from
being issued to writing history which
made a critical and analytic process
would move away from what history
service and turn into a consensus but he
has much the same poses for to the same
effect the restaurant choose only major
left
for history witnesses from both sides
immediately to the field and to borrow
an expression carbide or so men then a
confidence voices were among them the
former resistance fighters who have
particularly sensitive to how their
story would be told of course he started
quickly set to work as early as october
44 a condition of the history of the
occupation abrasion of france was
estimation during auspices of the
ministry of national attention is
focused on the history of an assistant
the first stage consisted of fighting
and collecting documents supplementing
by interviewing witnesses the resistance
is first of all a patriotic five for the
liberation of the fatherland I'm
coaching amin Shelly nineteen sixty year
later earlier 959 the cavity for the
history of the Second World War as the
BCBG one at launch the preparation of
the chronology of the resistance
actually contain wondered Alicia and
accountability
information first of all clearly the
actions sabotage MSHA's airship brought
landing landing operation by the nike
the balance of the reverberation seconds
the repression value true pirate must be
noted it is organized or perish the SS
at the resistance thurs placed as we
head for the collective movement
demonstrations drives finally one was
not again the bureaucracy of the race
with the creation of departments
pointment and general functionaries
Heather Poole asserting the archive is
not a neutral act it is conditioned by
the definition of the filthy document
you turn the conditions conditions the a
narrative framework that guidance
started with these archives and also for
many years material was collected as a
function of the Supreme objectives and
resistance said to himself to itself
because reality back off liberated
bhavana it is thus oddly establishing
that nothing in the chronology team will
not mention or even touched on the
rescue efforts on the organization that
works to save Jews when the committee
for the history of the Second World War
was collecting archival documents
nice the center for contemporary which
remain patient the CD GC located on the
very same street was doing much the same
thing relations between two groups are
excellent indeed indeed perhaps too
close because when the committee turned
up a document that might introduce you
just set it off to the CDJ see this
creation of two different archives gave
rise to two kernels from graphical
enterprises which room ahead without
ever coming into contact one group
focused on the chronicles of France the
other on the others of the Jews in
1948-49 the cdjs yet published 19
studies the dominance time does impose
its own rules especially
because the Jews across it first of all
consolidate their status in the New
France that was emerging under the
auspices on a particular vision of the
resistance two of the first aid agency
bjc studies both of them published in
1947 dealt with it ruthlessly resistance
Jack Lazarus 30 go back and grab
includes contribute contributions for
analysis don't pass both does everything
include where earth and weaknesses the
formula offered its own his own
testimony whereas the second presented
more vinegary both ways I list which did
not keep them from integrating the two
struggle into the dominant rhetoric the
hair is Jewish combatants occupied
center stage what are the aspects of the
body historiography produced by the city
city JC was indeed to include the Jews
in the glorification of the mythical
resist ask that was dominant a bedtime
the centrality of political and military
character of the resistance in the city
GCC DJ system earliest publication
favorite the memory of the organization
free to google the service group to
which go through and as
but he also promoted the narrative of
the Jewish communists in the internal
put Jewish political arena the matter
have created a region diverse and the
ground press both english and in french
and have been famous for spectacular of
the action of the French public scene in
those years the currents party was
really best to appropriate to deserve
the actions accomplished by his
reasoning and suppress the fact that
those were kept them out where
foreigners and opportune and encourage
young people from the underground which
can be suppressed was published in
nineteen fifty another title la crise on
TRC spookfest shopping in the end the
general term anti-racist press conveyed
a message it was acceptable to the
public at large while the convocation
self-service physical needs of the twist
colonist within the community in perfect
face with the dominant notions the
windows diamo publishes tribute to the
jewish eros of the french resistance to
the title b school in 1960s to when the
position moves down the forefront of a
jewish resistance and versus heroes of
the French Resistance
come is Scott part in internal Judy bait
thus everything conspired to marginalize
rescue it was also in 1947 that the cdjs
published a book on the activity of the
Treaty Organization in France under
occupation in order and I'm quoting
society as a chance and founder and
president of the CJC to acquire readers
with a passive resistance mute at
Memphis put up went to Jewish
organization and charities these are
tempos nanas in the face of the commies
attack of this organization and give him
the atmosphere at the time this study
did not enjoy the prestige attached to
attached to our resistance so Mauricio
Jews had to sneak into the CDJ see
historiography the image of reducing
French society was at the heart of these
artistes perpetration but they were not
equipped to challenge the dominance
representation of the resistance the
study studies produced by the CDJ see
were intended only for a handful of
subscribers and no historians ever made
reference to them the census periodical
the moon / mystery search that had been
carried out reproducing on chemical
document
but none of this was ever incorporated
within French French historiography true
the history of the resistance it laughs
was shunted from the sidelights by this
color by the scholar the world is to
closing time eventually however to quite
full rights in academia starting in the
mid 60s and even also after the
establishment of the st to destroy
fresno in 1970 this was a photography
nevertheless when it was decided in 1964
to include studies and articles about
the period 1939-1945 in the bibliography
with your lucky i'm reading this one off
and who bibliography of the issue of
frost nobody was left out thus the
continuation of the situation the war
years relegated relegated the story of
the rescue of Jews to the margins of
historical party the blossoming of all
coaster in the Western world well only
the appearance of you trends in
historiography brought some change to
this situation until occasion before
what came to be known as the pack
stallion revolution
the genocide of European Jewry made a
brief appearance in the French public
business in debates in delays that
spilled over from the jewish press and
cultured the public spotlight and the
unique nature of the Oracles following
the publication by Unleashed at-bats the
last of the jask which one the click on
Kobe 1915 on the publication of
bojangles Treblinka in 1966 the authors
of these two bestsellers said the
extermination of the Jews at the center
of the world which however then more
with a Jewish response to the euro cause
then we do reverse itself it was the
Jewish response that provoked feels a
bit bent no both Jews and non-jews were
reflected on juice non violent reaction
is kind of debate reinforce the accents
of what had been written since right
after the war the juice helpful back
that not allowed themselves to be led
like dance to slaughter Jewish colonies
and Zionists of the Jewish combat
organization were once again Harlan
injuries frost this was only the
three of a radical change in perception
of the unique nature of the show I the
Western world as a old as in France in
particular this change was also linked
to the historiography of France during
what the first referred to as black ian
years text Robert Paxton the Vichy
regime can occupy the center of a
historical revision that we inserted the
war years into the chain of French
history and the social history of an era
we she stopped being an accident product
of the vaccinations of a handful of
conspirators the conspirators the name
between the national revolution had
better salt and implemented and this
decision to collaborate it's Nazi
Germany the autonomy of wishes
anti-semitic policy and participation in
the implementation of the final solution
from these were no longer taboo with a
certain lag utter the
historiography of the French Resistance
also to commuter critical inquiry
replace apology the picture painted by
generation of historians was richer more
complex more lens police police to
evaluate your social history that
study of resistance by women gain energy
Timothy and the spotlight shifted from
the leaders to the right-hand side at
the same time the notion of the civilian
resistance was promoted by Jack Cena and
lead to the study of the peripheral
circle that have supported LCD approved
of the resistant structures the
sociologist ed come aboard attracted
more to cure ethical analysis and
untouched by the skins request by the
witnesses and the archive it added
assemble the earth historians to define
before they describe and analyze in
server to these developments the content
with it within which the history of the
rest of the Jews could be written in
developed was agitated chiefly by the
issues of memories memory and
commemoration while Robert Peston
incorporated the anticipated policies of
the Jewish regime into his words to the
stand of the national revolution policy
of collaboration marcello first sermon
pity highlighted similar beauty nice
portrait of family home Andrew
the unique character of the showa was
emerging the changes in French Jewish
demography starting from the arrival of
the refugees from North Africa in the
early sixties followed by the photo to
the six-day war a walk to his memory and
these are college whoo whoo soo is one
reason for the new centrality of the
show up in the debates that were always
in the news starting in the early 80s
you want to call the obsessional face of
the fishy synchro I will not redo the
few drops of memory that eventually led
to Jack she lacks acknowledgments
acknowledgments of france deals in the
passage cheshire medieval instantly but
in a speech he delivered delivered of
July to 60 90 95 s ceremonies to mark
the roundups of july 22 there was an old
life he said the following President
Shimon booty there is also from a
certain idea from what I suggest
generous Facebook instructions and
experience the
Strauss was never an issue it no longer
worth and for a long time in Paris it
was in the center of Libya and every
place with three people a free
friendship report was London and budget
by chanel allure is progress present one
and indivisible in the heart of those
French people those righteous among the
nations when the stormers doses risk
allowed to say exceptional speed has
written three quarters of the Jewish
community Leland Frost thereby giving
life to all that is best in first human
values to the values of Liberty justice
and tolerance that are the foundation of
the French identity and then alligators
for future and you figure and put a new
fear it just makes appearance in the
memorial landscape of the Second World
War the Righteous among the Nations who
became the righteous of France a science
Luce as demonstrated in the study of
which and drive drawing here
three-quarters of the jewish population
of rust oleum or hurt their lives the
celebration of the writers of froze
continued and even gathered speed in
subsequent years the invaders southern
entry into the
I'm January 18 2007 the hire of France
was cleans the vicious regime deals in
the deportation of the Jews to the cast
was balanced by the efforts of tens of
thousands citizens those writers across
suddenly we saw an encoding saha dance
version again we saw the partial
substitution of the figure of the
righteous for that of the resistance
fighter the implications of this rate
redistribution of course the pill goes
clearly in a series of films
broadcasting from talking up every day
18 2008 that day and the next prime time
viewers of the very public network
phones do were treated to to 90 minutes
fixed realize documentaries on the
French Resistance that the first West
title live free or die the second we
to save the Jews starting four days
later on the less popular network and as
an earth power for and ended up for
fifty to be used to have the same
costume every detail watch read French
through this television event which was
almost eight hours long there was a
switch from a veggie stars that was
understood as political and mid to low
resistance the German occupation of the
country to the notion of the spirit of
resistance shared by the entire French
people which found in his natural
combination in resistance to corrosion
because the behavior both French people
who share the Jews are afraid from
forming on fugitive Jews was now
paradigmatic of the spirit of the entire
resistance in this social environment
portraits of favorite with the rescue
operation that had been organized and
financed by Jewish organizations
assisted by some charitable as a French
non-jewish associations
from a point of the portrait of the
society with resisting the oppressor in
pleasant disregard the historical truth
or a fair society and of the ages of the
crazy stuff it was totally interface
with a spirit net movie is pictures as I
can mobilize to settle to the frost the
rescue of Jerusalem which slipped into
resistance studies by the back door has
come to occupy of the room which now
shares with the political and military
resistance this came from why we
endorsed by many eminent historians with
notable exception of joining everybody
up and on your soul there were no
protest about against this big picture
of the resistance or its role in the
rescue of the Jews now that the Jews had
found a place in freshest Oreo cookie
pans historiography that was more
attention to the restaurant juice by
Jewish organizations let us remain an
internal Jewish concern relevant to the
definition of the Jewish resistance as a
reaction to the previous reaction some
football the true meaning of Jewish
resistance must be found in the
organization's of rescue efforts
resistance to the showa that should be
listing which from the franchisee stars
this excluded the Jewish calories from
the
Christmas is from because they had
pursued goals set by the party the three
social organization design is now we're
gonna polish the civic space of Jewish
resistance realizar is a representative
of this school it is booked the
resistance read on horse retarded in
English translation to make it thesis or
obvious rescue as resistance how the
Jewish organizations for the conversion
from follow I mean sorry that you put on
the same friend you went on to publish
the liquid issues about not to sweat
said to the two stories remain distant a
Jewish resistance different in its
nature on one hand and rescue efforts
that included the activities of non-jews
on the Android those stories for the
strong ingredients of ideology the
former propose a little definition of
specifically Jewish resistance limits
limited
efforts the second echo the
commemoration of the righteous of past
and focus on the world arc individual
terms like Jewish resistance rescue of
Jews righteous person rescuers
individual organized actions were marked
by the vagueness that served ideological
objectives or a code memory issues but
the rescue enterprise still occupied is
negligible
poorly defined role in the history of
the resistance in the technological sa
other necessary to the ranking points86
without now I described the egg you to
the people and oppression and
persecution as humanitarian resist the
rest of the truth naturally fell into
this category this amounted to making
historiographical use of analytical
pattern born from the war period without
the slightest rehabilitation pretty
syndication and connotation particularly
as regards to our high school in
practice by focusing on the rescuers
motives and the results of the
Constitution the humanitarian
perspective transformed the widgets into
a
the object of history that was always
marginalizing the corporation between
Jews and non-jews in organizing racial
dimension Z imposing censorship division
between rescuers and beatings these two
stars or perhaps which say three stories
that of the franchisee stars that on the
rescue of the Jews by non-jews and even
the Jewish resistance the fact remains
that in general its humanitarian Medal
the restroom resistance is not really
penetrated to shop then shop mental
boundaries of the truth let me offer by
way of conclusion one example in the
historical dictionary of a late start
publishing 2006 the author of the entry
of Garland hi Tess obliged to justify
his inclusion in the world and I'm 40 in
the network darlin primaries appearing
among the wait staff member it is
because his activities
if he was straight established in the
consideration of the resistance which
made it possible for is covering
remaining frost such as john d malik to
move on to another state of action
teleport not all these in fact necessary
to justify price in cluttering the
dictionary it is also exercised that
rescue efforts were only an initial
stage that let those involved become
full-fledged resistance fighters let me
propose an alternative to this sentence
one legend in my own single support a
historical study on the rescue of the
Jews it's relentless and then putting
myself from from the very beginning of
the occupation the trade days in ethical
value fry represent one of the earliest
stages in the consolidation of a racist
resistance in France the one that
devoted himself to rescue operation this
form of resistance developed further
when the persecution of the Jews reaches
head there to the combined activities of
very social food and Jewish organization
supported by many in New York
the organized movements all those stars
play only a marginal role in this
enterprise for this is indeed the crux
of the divorce between resistance and
rescue that continues to mark
contemporary historiography in France
another approach not damaged nerves of a
riot resistance in the slightest and if
required consideration of each books
made this is witnesses to the history of
the rest of the Jews in France cannot be
studied in isolation it must be part of
an integrated perspective at least to
think that leads to thinking about the
resistance as a all organised and
unorganised Jewish and non-jewish
rating don't go away go down fighting we
can generally take a couple of minutes
for questions are there is someone who
wishes to ask a question